Aquaman Aquaman does whatever I quote an
that doesn't work so DC's last go this
year I should is there only week they
came up this year I think in theaters
anyways so yeah Aquaman I went into this
with pretty low expectations it's not
like something with you know like Batman
V Superman or even Justice League where
I saw the trailers and was like this
looks bad it was more of a case of I saw
Charles oh no and could be fun so it's
kind of all I expected I expected it to
be fun an enjoyable way to kill a couple
of hours and going in with those
expectations yeah it was fun it's uh
it's not great but it's certainly like I
I'm I'm just relieved at a DC movie just
being willing to be fun because honestly
being fun covers a lot of sins because I
mean like you get something like Batman
V Superman and it takes itself so
seriously now if something takes itself
super seriously and it works awesome if
it takes itself super seriously and it
doesn't work that's an extra level of
pain so if something is aiming to be fun
even if like on paper I can go that's a
problem that doesn't work this is
unnecessary there's too much of this I
want more of that but if I still had fun
like something went right so what works
here well honestly Jason Momoa I do like
this Aquaman I think this is probably
the best performance he's he's given as
it's only the second performance he's
given as this Aquaman because I'm not
gonna count the Cameo and BBS but he's
good he's got he's got a real great
presence and charisma and I liked the
rough-and-tumble edge that they're going
for it feels right while at the same
time he does have that sense of heroism
to him I really appreciate that as much
as this is tackling one of the more
grands kind of epic scale Aquaman's
stories that it doesn't lose sight of
the fact that he is a hero and that
basically the first thing we see Aquaman
doing is I've you know outside of an
opening flashback is rescuing people and
even midway through the movie and in an
act to fight where there are civilians
around he's rescuing people we never
lose sight of that element of him and
that's good because if we don't feel fur
if we don't either feel for him or root
for him as a hero then it would be
really easy to lose sight of why do we
care about this conflict at all because
it's a guy we don't like trying to
depose another guy who you know we like
even less so thankfully it keeps it
keeps all that in line so all that works
pretty well Mara feels a bit
underdeveloped as a character but Amber
Heard plays her well and has pretty
decent chemistry with Momoa honestly I
get more of a buddy chemistry than all
man to chemistry with them so when it
inevitably went there which I knew it
was going to because I mean they're
they're married in the comics or have
been I can't I can't keep track of what
actually is the case anymore in anything
but historically they've been married so
I knew that was gonna happen anyway but
it still kind of irritated me and also
the ridiculousness of the specific
moment when they kissed also was a
little like really but but not she she
plays a solid the rest of the cast is is
fine black man is pretty good arm is
decent he's not a character I really
like so I guess that means that Patrick
Wilson did a pretty good job Nicole
Kidman is
just kind of there but you know she's
not completely phoning it in so that
works I forget the guys name so
apologies there but the guy who was
Jango Fett in the prequels playing
Aquaman's dad he's pretty good and then
we've got you know all the other people
kind of scattered throughout like Dolph
Lundgren and Willem Dafoe who are fine
they feel a little too good for the
parts they're given but they work in
there and they're putting the effort in
and then and it's all fine
visually it's it's pretty the effects
aren't always convincing or realistic
but they're usually pretty and they're
usually nice to look at and they're
usually pretty well designed in some
cases there's a really nice variety to
the action especially because we we get
some real brawling knock-down drag-out
fights we get you know the the battles
between Arthur and arm you know the
Trident fights which feel much more like
superhero smackdowns and then you know
we've got grander scale battles we've
got some legit kaiju style action going
on here so that's that's kind of cool
it's a pretty good mix but overall in it
is that element of fun that keeps the
whole thing chugging along through the
fact that honestly it's kind of bloated
it's probably about a half hour longer
than it should be and I could have to
top my head think of 15 minutes that you
could cut easy most of it the
expositional flashback stuff because we
don't really gain much benefit from the
opening flashback or really any time we
saw Arthur as a younger person than the
adult like especially oh god the bits we
get of teenage Arthur being trained by
Willem Dafoe that teenage actor was not
good but even setting that aside those
scenes don't have much they that sort of
the problem is that this film this film
is doing a lot and it's probably doing a
little bit too much because it is
through flashback
covering Aquaman's origin and in
relation to that the nature of his
parents relationship has to talk about
Atlantis the entire political dynamic of
Atlantis the other characters from
Atlantis and all their individual
motivations black manta a treasure hunt
a battle for the throne you know that
it's it's doing a lot it has to lay a
lot of groundwork for it to move ahead
to where it is and part of me I'm kind
of toward I find myself going back on
this guys remember back and forth on
this because I remember while I was
watching it thinking I kind of wish that
the only villain we were dealing with
was Black Manta and it's not that ocean
master is bad it's just that I felt that
black mantle was better introduced
better characterized and better
motivated for what he was doing then
orme was because arm his goals are a
little bit too grand and nebulous at the
same time so like black mana he's he
comes into conflict with Aquaman because
he's a pirate that's like his family
legacy in his family business and so
he's committing violent crime on the
high seas that gives off from his
intention that's why they butt heads
then as a result of what happens he
blames Aquaman for the death of somebody
he cares about so now we've got a
revenge motive for him to go after
Aquaman cool follow all of it make
perfect sense or him on the other hand
is doing all this stuff he's doing to
unite the kingdom's to wage war on the
surface will be cuz I mean like they say
why
like he talked about all the damage the
the surface world has done but like why
why now what what is the catalyst for
him deciding that now is when he has to
push it into a full-on war with the
surface he's just kind of doing it
because he's the bad guy and that's what
he has to do again or isn't awful but
like comparatively I thought Black Manta
was a much better villain and black man
has kind of treated a bit more as a
henchman here and doesn't get nearly as
much screen time
oh also black mana the between the way
he's shot and and everything
way more intimidating as a threat that
worm was but even though part of me was
going I kind of wish it was only dealing
with Black Manta I do understand why
they brought in all the other stuff
because well okay so in a time when we
could be assured that this was gonna see
gonna get a sequel and at this point it
almost definitely well it's making
really good money
it's bait it's basically making the
money that a Star Wars movie would have
made if it was released in December like
it should have been you frigging morons
but anyways it's it's taken you know
that the the blockbuster in December
spot that Star Wars had the last couple
of years so it's making good money and
probably will get a sequel but that
wasn't a guarantee because you know
looking at what happened with Batman V
Superman with Justice League there was
no guaranteeing that we're gonna get
another crack at this so I don't blame
them for for not going okay look we
can't do a bill we can't like start with
Black Manta and only do that and then
set up the throne of Atlantis stuff
because what if we never get a chance to
do that and that's what a lot of people
are really gonna want to see and that's
true so I I find myself torn on the
question of whether or not they should
they should have been tackling all this
at once I mean suppose maybe they could
have cut Black Manta except I really
liked Black Manta I don't know it did
just cut it just kind of is what it is
on that level and but and like I said it
just adds to a slightly blurred in film
I remember checking my watch towards the
tail line not because I was bored just
because I was like man this thing's
still going and it keeps throwing
additional sort of complications and set
pieces after it feels like a boy that
was the big triumphant moment no okay
we're not done
all right and I didn't necessarily get
burned out or bored by it it just it
just keeps going but yeah overall it was
it was good it was fun and that's kind
of it
like I I don't have a lot more to say
other than other than that that's what
it is at the end of the of the day it
was a fun time at the movies I don't
feel the need to see it again I'm
definitely not gonna see it in the
theater again it's the sort of thing
that like I wouldn't say no if someone's
like hey I've never seen that how do you
feel about watching that I know you've
seen it before I probably show you know
yeah sure why not but I'm not sure I'll
ever go out of my way to see it again
but I'm glad that I saw it the once
there you go take that for whatever it's
worth
so Aquaman have you seen it what you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about a whole bunch of stuff
to do because there's buttons and links
and all this other stuff oh and by the
way I know that the new black mirror
thing comes out today the day that this
goes up I am gonna deal with that but
like that's gonna be a time commitment
for me to get all the way through so
don't pester me about that anyway coming
back to this whatever your thoughts are
now in the comments let's talk about it
whole other bunch of stuff to do buttons
links link to the patreon if you want to
support me and this channel that would
be fantastic if you don't there's other
links to check out don't want to click
them that's fine too because at the end
of the day you are the council I just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]